there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products from
january to test for ourselves elf has
been killing it with its new releases
lately and we need to talk about this
new power grip primer because it's
excellent
immediately i compared it to my milk
hydro grip primer they are virtually
identical in terms of texture and how
they apply except this elf one is
obviously cheaper just like the hydro
grip primer it creates a really nice
tacky base for foundation that's meant
to make your makeup last longer my
foundation blended out really nicely on
top of this it wasn't peeling or doing
anything out of the ordinary i took some
pictures about five to six hours after i
applied and i do think my makeup lasted
really well even my blush which is
literally always the first thing to
disappear on my face elf also released
this powder foundation in its camo line
i'll be honest powder foundations are
just not my thing i don't like how they
look on my skin but the camo line has
had nothing but hits so i had to try
this the powder is so soft and it blends
out very easily it definitely evened out
my skin tone and blurred some of those
areas i have of discoloration
however it just looks powdery i don't
think it gives my skin the most
flattering texture i forgot to set it
with some spray to see if that helps at
all but i don't see myself liking this
even with setting spray to melt it in a
bit this is not for me
i love trying new mascaras this is the
makeup revolution 5d lash pal mascara
it's supposed to make it look like
you're wearing falsies the size of this
brush is astronomical oh my god but i
love a big natural bristle mascara brush
right away i could tell that this
mascara was doing a really nice job of
thickening my lashes and the more i
built it up it gave my lashes this nice
little curl i naturally have straight
lashes and i hate curling them so i was
really happy with the effect this
mascara gave them also i love how you
push the cap down to open it it's really
satisfying to me the fenty beauty
kilowatt freestyle highlighter is
definitely not new but madison beer said
she uses this one in ginger binge slash
moscow mule as a blush and everyone
bought it including me
fenty highlighters are more glittery
than [ __ ] so i was a little nervous
about how this was gonna look on me and
the texture on my cheeks it was
definitely more metallic looking because
it's a highlighter and not a blush but i
actually did not hate this at all i did
have to go over it with my sponge to
take away some of that glitter but the
color and the glow it brought to my
cheeks was super pretty i don't think
you need the specific product for this
kind of effect but if you're gonna try
it i recommend sticking to the side with
less glitter charlotte tilbury just
dropped this beautiful skin foundation
the claims on the box were so funny to
me like skin tone looks more even by up
to 210
sure this foundation had a way thicker
consistency than i expected and i think
because of that it didn't really melt
into my skin the way i wanted it to the
coverage lean more on the lighter side
so i went back into certain areas and
added some more it's definitely
buildable but i'm not obsessed with how
my skin is looking i don't think it
looks cakey it just looks like i'm
wearing foundation and it's not as skin
like as the name would have you think do
i think my skin tone looks more even by
up to two hundred and ten percent
i can't really say but this is just okay
to me i saw a tick tock that said this
sigma renew lip oil is a possible dupe
for the 35 dior lip oil so i had to
compare the two because i'm obsessed
with the dior lip oil it feels so
nourishing on the lips and it has that
big doe foot applicator that feels so
cushiony i could literally apply this
all day the sigma lip oil looks so much
like it look at these applicators
they're almost identical the sigma one
is hydrating and shiny and it gives you
that moisturizing non-sticky feeling it
feels so much like the dior one the only
discernible difference i found between
the two is that the sigma one has no
scent and the dior one does it's 22
dollars which is still really pricey for
a lip oil and it only comes in four
shades but i think this is a really good
dupe highly recommend
you guys have been asking me to try out
some rare beauty on this show so i
picked up the new warm wishes effortless
bronzer stick and the always an optimist
soft radiant setting powder let's talk
about the bronzer stick first i
immediately got nervous swatching it on
the back of my hand because it looked so
red but i was so shocked when i saw how
easily it blended in i don't know why i
applied this like it was a contour stick
but it worked out for me the texture of
this is something special it's super
smooth and soft and velvety and it
doesn't blend into nothing you still see
that color you still get the warmth of a
bronzer it looked way less red when i
applied it to my face so i was actually
really happy with this now the setting
powder i'll admit right now i made a
mistake getting the medium shade i
should have gone for light medium but i
expected this to be way more sheer than
it actually was i normally use a
translucent powder so using a setting
powder with color was new for me
applying it with my sponge was an
immediate no it made my skin look so
patchy and weird my powder brush was
definitely the way to go the powder was
super finely milled and it gives your
skin that soft blur that looks really
pretty it made my skin look a lot
smoother on the side where i used my
brush it's still a little patchy in
terms of color but that's obviously my
fault because this is not my color i
definitely need to try this again in my
appropriate shade and finally let's talk
about the new nyx thicket stick it brow
gel it's described as a thickening brown
mascara if you look really closely you
can see those little fibers that are
supposed to make your brows look fuller
and fluffier i actually bought this for
myself and used it once and thought it
was just okay but i had no idea you were
supposed to layer it so i did that this
time around and my brows came out so
much better i'm obsessed with how this
right brow looks the left one not so
much but that's always my problem bro i
kind of wish this had a smaller brush
because i kept accidentally spreading
the product outside of my brows but i do
like the natural full effect that you
get with this
[Music]